this mission to save a five-year-old boy
has gripped morocco for days
rayanne fell into the bottom of the well
while playing outside on tuesday he's
been trapped ever since
the well is in the town of bob beret
it's 32 meters deep but his face is too
narrow for rescue workers to go down and
reach him they've cut a hole into a hill
next to the well hoping they can dig a
horizontal tunnel to get the boy
there
they turned on the light on the phone's
camera and dropped it down so they
discovered that the kid is still there
and he was still talking i heard him
myself he was begging us to save him
the weather is cold and it's unclear
whether the boy has taken any food water
or oxygen that's been channeled to him
i hope he will come out of this okay
it's like one of our own children has
fallen we are praying for his safety
he's one of our children
the hills have turned into a
construction site with hundreds of
people surrounding the area anxiously
waiting for rayanne to be rescued
millions in morocco are watching the
operation unfold live on television on
social media support is also growing
rescue workers say they're getting
closer to the boy but there's a risk of
a landslide
we're living in a true catastrophe in
this area with our son ryan we pray to
god for good news to make us and all
moroccans happy
a helicopter is standing by to take
riyan to hospital and across morocco and
the world people are also waiting and
hoping he'll be saved
taxia lopez obayan al jazeera